I'd like to take this opportunity in
introducing the winner they got him
award last year for the best acting role
mr. Ernest Borgnine
thank you
the nominees for the best actress are
Carol Dweck Baker and babydoll
Ingrid Bergman and Anastasia Katherine
Hepburn in the Rainmaker
Nancy Kelly in the bad seed and Deborah
Carr in the king and i gamble oh please
the winner Ingrid Bergman in Anastasia
you ain't well it's a privilege to have
been asked to be here in case Ingrid won
this award and now that she has it's a
privilege to will try to thank her for -
thank you for her but alas I have no way
of knowing the exact depth and degree of
her emotion when she finally hears the
news that she's received it so dear
Ingrid if you can hear me now or if you
see this televised film I want you to
know that each of the other nominees and
all the people with whom you worked on
anastasiya and the dear hitch Leo
McCarey and every one of us here denied
them in New York send you our
congratulations our love our admiration
and every affectionate salt